[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
nous allons faire un tour de l'actualité
une actualité assez mémorielle puisque
l'on parle beaucoup des son temps de
l'armistice de 1918 et pour en parler
florence mercadé choqué vous êtes
avocate bonjour jean stéphane manceau
professeur réalisé le site et de verser
50 1 ça va bien une fois n'est pas
coutume mais non vous êtes toujours
merci une élégance rare
merci tout ça c'est un métier jean
baptiste duclair il ya aussi d'une
élégance racée moi je réalise mon repas
complément voilà vous hanter une
toujours à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin hausse
directement tout à fait et en interne
les nerfs bonjour police
vous enseignez à sciences po et vous
publiez avec michel verpeaux passé comme
vous le dites de paf
exactement je sais tout à fait des
textes consignes constitutionnelles et
politiques
alors c'était c'était un livre culte un
peu de l'aude et on charrie finalistes
de cette une reprise de l'ouvragé de
maurice duverger il y avait les textes
et documents constitutionnel et
politique de mémoire et on la remet au
goût du jour donc il a il a subi
sérieux lifting on a mis des liens on a
on s'est autorisé aussi à commenter
chacun des documents ce que n'avait pas
fait - et du verger
mais voilà donc c'est un voyage au
travail voilà voyage en est constituée
sur la vie politique travailler un
document précieux évidemment pour
comprendre un peu l'évolution de la
constitution puisque ce qui est dans la
constitution et en fait l'euro et le
rôle du prendre du conseil
constitutionnel est majeur justement tu
es à bonbons aux enfants
parade du reste de l'actualité après
mais est ce que est ce que le le rôle du
conseil constitutionnel de plus en plus
important dans notre république
les spécialistes vous adressez à moi je
te non violence il est incontestablement
plus important puisque il il ya eu là
une révision constitutionnelle en 2008
qui a justement permis que désormais les
citoyens
enfin même les justiciables de façon
plus générale peuvent se saisir
constitutionnel à l'occasion d'un procès
on peut l'invoquer alors rien et un
système de filtres qui organisé par les
juridictions suprêmes la cour de
cassation en conseil d'état mais le le
conseil constitutionnel peut être saisi
d'une autre manière que la procédure
prévue depuis 1658 donc il est saisi
disons plus fréquemment et puis son rôle
s'accroît en ce sens qu'il s'autorise à
l'est toujours beaucoup plus loin dans
son contrôle et donc ce qui se traduit
pas forcément par un nombre de censure
beaucoup plus important mais il est
beaucoup de disent même qu'il est plus
intrusif il va vraiment comment
dirais-je dans le
jusqu'aux confins un petit peu de la
frontière entre le droit et la science
politique et la politique c'est à dire
que parfois ils s'autorisent à examiner
les choix qui sont parfois pris en
opportunités par les représentants de la
nation sous couvert d'interpréter la
constitution c'est pas systématique mais
à certaines décisions qui sont parfois
critiquée voilà la décision qui a été
prise sur le principe de fraternité
est-ce que d'emmener on va sur le
domaine politique
effectivement c'est quoi ont de beau le
foot et c'est au sujet de l'hébergement
des dérives des réfugiés sans papiers
attendent et jay-z oui voilà il était
interrogé sur ce point là il conseil
constitutionnel enfin je dis ça sous
sous le contrôle d éminents spécialistes
mais le conseil constitutionnel a estimé
que le principe de fraternité est un
principe constitutionnel et que le fait
d'héberger par fraternité des hommes et
des femmes
grand devait être de les protéger donc
mon époque quand même c'est vrai quand
même pas la république des juges
certains noms alors ce qui est
intéressant aussi à mon avis et on
terminera là dessus je veux pas être
trop longue sur cette question mais je
trouve que le concept fonctionne elle a
bien réussi sa mutation aussi de la
modernité c'est à dire qu'il a réussi à
lancer une application un rapport public
annuel maintenant et sous l'égide de son
nouveau président les décisions ont même
été complètement vous rédigez laurent
fabius
bon on a un juge qui rentre un petit peu
dans dans son temps et qui apprend à
aussi à se faire connaître c'était un
petit peu le problème du conseil
constitutionnel pendant ces dernières
années c'est voilà le caractère un peu
obscurantistes parfois de ses méthodes
de travail
il a maintenant un peu mieux comment ça
fonctionnait à faire un conseil qui
communique beaucoup donc ça change et
puis pour nous c'est avec les questions
préjudicielles de consignes a dit et il
n'a jamais rendu autant de décisions sur
des dix dernières années c'est à
s'intéresser à beaucoup accru son rôle
et son importance dans la dent dans la
vie citoyenne finalement question
préjudicielle c'est que souvent un
procès ce soir pendant un procès sont
dans le temps se corse et voilà la
question que j'évoquais tout à l'heure à
la wii soit en haïti soit le juge saisi
seul le conseil constitutionnel et les
avocats s'en sont saisis match énorme et
le mont houy l'utilisent beaucoup c'est
vrai pas toujours à bon escient mais bon
dans ces questions qui étaient
extrêmement tassant c'est vrai et puis
on a on a revu pas mal de corpus
juridique anciens qu'on a voilà du pot
qu'on a un qu'on a mis en conformité
avec ses textes constitutionnels et
politiques c'est donc pu thémis droit et
donc à une certaine bezina et michel
verpeaux 7
alors on va redescendre d'un cran parce
qu'on va parler des sens à ta mère
après l'existence les sources comme eux
non c'est vrai qu on a vu alors pendant
cette itinérance mémorielle c'est comme
ça qu'on c'est comme ça qu'on en parle
en ce moment dit oui hier sega ministre
c'est bien mais on voit bien la rayer
une colère car dd des français que
rencontre le président de la république
d'ailleurs huit ans et viendra peut-être
après ce que est ce que il n'ya pas une
sorte comme ça de croyance qu'il faut
aller voir les gens pour savoir ce qui
se passe enfin on aura peut-être après
mais sur le prix de l'essence d'alors si
on regarde en fait c'est une des yé eu
nicolas hulot qui avait failli le
candidat en 2007 qui avait demandé à
tous les candidats d'un prêt public de
s'engager à taxer enfin le le pétrole de
façon à ce que réduire la consommation
donc tout le monde s'y est engagé et au
fond c'est une continuité de la
politique qui a été menée depuis là
qu'on voit aujourd'hui et dont on
trouvera les conséquences puisque c'est
vrai que ça coûte de plus en plus c'est
côté de ça il faut savoir que c'est vrai
que en fait ce qu'on le prix du baril a
déjà un petit peu augmenté mais c'est
vrai que en fait c'est quand même là le
prix du carburant est quand même le
record man du prix qui
a le plus de taxe sur la taxe donc il ya
des impôts sur l'impôt on paye une taxe
sur les produits pétroliers à laquelle
on a rajouté une espèce de taxe carbone
qui en effet correspond aux soucis
écologiques
elle a augmenté considérablement cette
année une tva propre à cette équipe et
c'est eux et la tva général dessus donc
c'est à dire que bon dans dans un seul
prix à près de 4,4 taxation donc c'est
c'est à la fois les avantages de cette
taxation indirecte et qu'on les sent pas
trop mais précisément bon quand on
augmente une on est bon il ya ce souci
écologique il ya c'est vrai une
continuité je trouve que là néanmoins
c'est vrai que arrivé à dire que c'est
la suite d'une politique connue c'est
peut-être un peu c'est peut-être pas
complètement réel parce que là il ya
quand même une hausse continue et une
hausse qui a été accentuée par le
dernier gouvernement notamment sur le
diesel
bompard volonté politique évidemment de
par souci écologique mais c'est quand
même on est monté d'un cran
voilà par rapport à la logique de 2007
oui avec l'elysée parce que c'est vrai
l'idée c'était de taxer le diesel de la
même façon que tu es censé la
maintenance et et certains disent mais
alors pourquoi ne pas baisser la taxe
comprise par les forces pour la remettre
au niveau du diesel on pourrait aussi
envisager ça là dessus sur sur ce prime
je suis plutôt favorable
enfin c'est un peu comme les comme les
cigarettes porte de chez les gens de
fumer on augmente le paquet de
cigarettes
là on a une vraie problématique
écologique mais j'ai deux deux bémols là
dessus le premier c'est qu'il est fort
dommage qu'on ne sache pas où vont les
taxes enfin comment sont utilisés les
taxes parce que si je pense que si le
citoyen mais par des sénat qui montre
que l'appât tribut à l'environnement au
fond est relativement faible
c'est ça le problème cassis
au moins ces taxes la servait à
développer d'autres énergies
renouvelables ce serait plus
compréhensible pour le citoyen et je
pense que ça pose une question beaucoup
plus en amont et probablement plus
fondamental c'est le niveau de vie des
français et sur une dégradation du
niveau de vie des classes moyennes et
surtout ça des gens les gens qui
utilisent le diesel c'est souvent parce
qu'ils sont un peu loin
absolument et puis parce que ça a été
dans les moeurs françaises depuis dix
ans maintenant on a poussé poussé poussé
au diesel pendant l'année de l'anc et
maintenant voilà donc il ya un problème
plus large je pense qu'ils aient sur la
problématique de la répartition des
richesses et que les gens qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas contents c'est
parce que ça touche à leur porte-monnaie
et qui sont là à compter les centimes
quand il met qui font le plein d'essence
et que on a une vraie problématique de
problématiques salariale problématique
de niveau des salaires en france et je
pense que ça pose ce problème là de
façon plus générale plus que on augmente
le oui on augmente l'augmentent
l'essence parce que on a un problème
écologique avec des tas de gens qui
meurent du fait de la pollution ça c'est
on a des rapports réguliers là dessus
mais il ya un problème en un mot qu'on
personne neutre est finalement sur le
pouvoir d'achat alors d'un côté on dit
bilal et maintenant les salariés ou d'un
bulletin de salaire avec un aide plus
important parce que on a plus de charges
sur un certain nombre de points mais de
l'autre côté c'est ce que les français
ressentent en disant bah oui on a une
baisse des charges sur notre bulletin de
salaire en octobre donc on a un être
supérieur mais de l'autre côté ce net
supérieur on va le passer dans la pompe
à essence et du coup on n'est pas du
temps donc c'est vrai que voilà donc du
coup les gens disent voilà ça fait ça
fait une somme nulle et puis ça pose
aussi un problème de cohérence du si
slater tu l'as dit on a quand même eu
des politiques incitatives pour le
diesel plus justement les énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui on nous
apprend que donc il faut complètement
bannir le diesel et je crois qu'on n'a
pas je suis en accord là dessus on n'a
pas solution de repli encore
véritablement non viable donc du coup on
des utilisations
de fait le sens que vraiment les
français puissent trouver une solution
économiquement neutre de repli
parce que c'est là qu'ils reprennent
leur religion et qui rachète un autre
véhicule il a les moyens de racheter
cette halle véhicule et on revient
toujours sur un problème c'est d'être
finie est commun
whitera meetic à paris avec exactement
stéphane manceau oui moi je pense que le
carburant n'est pas assez cher
je je je oui enfin ça coûte cher mais
moi ça ne me je trouve ça normal ça ne
me gêne pas je ne mesure pas la qualité
de mon bien-être à mon pouvoir d'achat
je la mesure aussi à l'aune de par
exemple de la qualité des services
publics dont je peux disposer dans la
société dans laquelle nous vivons et je
trouve que connaissant plus ou moins
d'autres systèmes je trouve qu'on est
très bien le type donc je n'aime pas
cette polémique sur sur les histoires de
gilet jaune de machines lors qu'ils vont
bloquer le 17 novembre
je sais pas trop quoi n'aurait pas parmi
eux le 17 nov certainement pas je
marcherai peut-être pas accuser mal avec
un gilet jaune mais c'est très saignant
avec le bonnet rouge 2 sur wii je vous
le conseille un discours de citadins qui
la met sa vie en ce sens m pour les
inviter à 30 40 km de votre travail
c'est plus complet message en
disconviens pas si vous voulez mais je
pense que non il faudra que je sais pas
le litre soit 5 euros et là on pourra
commencer que peut-être on pourra enfin
commencer à apprécier
quand on vous quand vous pas dire que
vous donnez ministre des transports de
toute façon je n'ai pas le temps pour
l'instant on verra mais si vous voulez
non jeu quand vous quand vous réalisez
que dans un dans une agglomération quand
vous avez un taux de fréquentation des
transports en commun qui avoisine les 6
% il me semble que à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'était pas
loin de 6 6% de la population qui a pu
visionner utilisent les transports en
commun c'est un chiffre énorme
les gens vont se félicitait il ya
quelques années à saint quentin en
yvelines en disant allez compte regarder
6% la population qui a la qualité
d'usagers des transports en commun donc
voilà il ya beaucoup de gens qui
pourraient prendre les transports en
commun qui ne les prennent pas il ya des
expériences de gratuité qui sont tentés
dans certaines dans certaines
agglomérations alors qu'il fonctionne
c'est assez fragile mais ça commence à
fonctionner et là il ya on voit tout de
suite que les gens laissent leur
véhicule personnel je sais c'est toutes
ces affaires moi me voilà ne me gêne
beaucoup parce que il faut tout de même
voir à moyen et long terme
c'est aussi le rôle des élus de expliqué
il faut voir à long terme et à long
terme ce n'est pas tenable
tout cela n'est pas tenable et on sait
très bien que alors il ya polémique il
ya controverse sur l'histoire du pic
pétrolier vous savez le moment où oui la
production va commencer à baisser on
sait pas très bien alors certains disent
que c'est derrière nous on est déjà dans
la pente descendante d'autres disent en
2035 etc enfin il y aura un moment toute
façon les énergies non renouvelables par
définition ça se renouvelle pas et donc
où il faudra passer à autre chose et
puis alors on est là on se scandalise on
se désole de la démission de hulot dix
ans à l'écologie l'ogc en politique et
serra et puis bon alors c'est vrai ce en
zone rurale etc
il ya sans doute les autres c'est ce que
disait allez on sent dans une période de
transition qui écoute qui sont les
périodes compliquées quoi puisqu'il n'y
a pas là il n'y a pas en effet le de ce
point
r de transition mais de transition par à
coups on voit bien que dans ce qu'il
faudrait c'est une paire de transition
où on augmente le prix de l'essence mais
on multiplie parallèlement un certain
nombre de transports ou les transports
et les services publics fonctionnent
bien c'est pas forcément l'avis de tous
ceux qui utilisent quotidiennement c'est
peut être ça pour être bien même et
enfin il faut quand même aller pas trop
loin dans certains systèmes européens
pour voir à quel point ça fonctionne
beaucoup mieux qu'ailleurs c'est déjà un
lot de consolation quand je me regarde
je me désole mais quand je me compare je
me console est bon il ya mieux on peut
faire mieux c'est vrai et pourquoi pas
une quasi gratuité des transports etc
tout ça doit être étudiée mais ce ce
côté alors plus en plus récupération
politique de la grogne des gens et c'est
pas revenir sur le passé parce que c'est
un exemple dans ma commune le maire une
proposition de réaménagement urbain
complet de l'entrée est à l'entrée de la
commune il ya une station service et la
danse dans le cadre de son projet il
supprime la station service donc ça
divise il y avait une réunion avec avec
tous les citoyens et ça a été
extrêmement drôle parce que il y avait
des citoyens qui hurlent et en disant
non regardez notre nation alors qu'il y
en a une autre
quatre kilomètres plus loin donc enfin
même plusieurs et ils disaient mais
l'avenir c'est plus l'essence moi mr il
faut que je me projette à 20 ans
d'accord mais il en faut bien un dock
station essence il y en a il a quatre
qui en a une à quatre kilomètres une ode
à 5km à ya moyen de ceux de toute façon
ils disent c'est vraiment c'est très mal
et c'est vrai que c'est très très moche
à l'entrée de la ville c'est pas très
joli
et alors on voyait les gens ce vraiment
se déchirer dans le cadre du débat et
c'était c'était dans paris on est pas
loin de l'abattre olitique c
là que prône cette ambiance au c'est à
dire qu'on n'est pas loin de 5 euros non
mais je crois que il ya une véritable
question qui est celle de ce qu'on nous
propose
en alternative est la question de
l'affectation aussi si on explique et si
on voit effectivement que l'argent qu'on
a payé en plus sur ce carburant sert à
réhabiliter les transports à qu en
commun en les rendant moins cher plus
sécure walid al awad était pétri mais
laisse pas pourquoi pas nous nous ne
pouvons vivre de belles accéléré ces
derniers temps il paraît que les je
crois qu'ils sont à peu près à 25 km
heure sur les trottoirs en ce moment
donc que c'est raide là aussi les
emmerder oui tombe rentrer ça dans le
code de la route menant les métros tweet
électrique pour essayer des contrôles et
donc en tout cas des alternatives
devraient exister qu'on contrôle qu'on
régule pour essayer de nous prouver
qu'on peut faire autrement et je crois
que dans ce cadre là ça deviendra plus
acceptable de payer plus cher mais c'est
vrai qu'on ne voit pas encore
et surtout avec cette question de
l'affectation des crédits on ne se rend
pas compte à quel point cet argent est
utile à autre chose peut-être qu'il
faudrait le démontrer un peu plus en
terme de communication jean baptiste
guittet
oui en fait il y à il ya deux exigences
en fait contradictoire mais sur
lesquelles tout le monde se rejoint je
crois c'est que d'une part on veut tout
simplement lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
et puis d'autre part on veut tout
simplement faire que les citoyens
français puissent ne pas être trop taxés
dans leur porte-monnaie puisque c'est
une des comptes une dépenses
incompressibles
et de ce point de vue-là je crois que
quand on regarde le prix de l'essence à
la pompe et et du diesel je crois qu'il
a quand même extrêmement élevé et si on
essaie d'examiner précisément cette
évolution en fait elle s'explique pour
70% par l'évolution du cours du pétrole
et pour 30% seulement par l'évolution de
la taxation
je me rappelle pas fait
vrai basse et le privé de l'état en
douce enfin il endossera la
responsabilité mais on souhaiterait lui
faire endosser la responsabilité de
l'évolution ça il faut il faut faire
attention et justement je crois que
cette enfin la taxation serait plus
intelligente si elle tenait compte de
l'évolution du cours du pétrole c'est à
dire que quelque part elle elle
diminuerait si le cours du pétrole
évoluent et et là on aurait quelque
chose de plus intelligent parce que ça
permettrait pour français moyen qui lui
en fait de ses intérêts ce qu'une seule
chose c'est combien il doit payer la
pompe
voilà de 2,2 dire qu'à un moment il a
une fourchette de 30 % et qu' il ne
suffit pas de plein fouet en fait
l'évolution du cours du pétrole avec un
impôt qui lui reste reste cette affiche
maintenant oui ça reste aussi complexe
et ça ne s'adaptent pas c'est vrai que
c'est un peu ça le problème j'avance pct
flotte entre le thé ipc eux ne l'est
plus les plus belles mais faute sur ce
mouvement du 17
novembre qu'elle vous ne participerez
temps passé avec l'amusement parce que
hier il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
faisait moi j'aime bien parce que les
blocages on va bloquer le 10 septembre
mais qui vont-ils bloqué sinon eux mêmes
enfin moi je le 17 novembre je ne serai
pas sur la route mais je regarderai ça
oui avec intérêt je sais gilet jaune
non mais je sais pas je prendrai mon
vélo où je prendrai le bus ce qui
m'arrive mais juste d'être je vais
passer par un autre
vous avez raison de parler de bonnets
rouges parce que il ya thème de gilet
jaune n'est pas neutre enfin ça fait
penser à ça aussi mais pas bonnet rouge
ça sentait bon le far breton et la la ça
sort ça ça pue le gasoil c'est toute la
différence des mouvements c'est de voir
comment il est parti c'est parti sur les
réseaux sociaux
oui la sortie ça et puis ça fait une
espèce de boule de neige et c'est pas
partie ni d'un parti politique où la
france est pas loin derrière
oui alors oui bon s'agrègent d'autres
soumis aussi non donc il dit à lézinnes
enfin montré patron oui mais une
opération politique d'un mouvement qui
au départ en effet est partie de quelque
chose de complètement neutre en fait
politiquement et syndicalement c'est pas
oui j'aime de parmesan
finalement on avait vu les chefs de
toutes les grèves mélenchon ou de toutes
les manifestations qui avaient été
faites pour voilà part parce aussi
syndicats par souci collectif était
content d visuellement tous les français
sans toucher finalement il ya un
mouvement qui part du bas de la base a
finalement à chaque prime en effet
facebook c'est ça c'est jacqueline mais
j'ai fait que je j'ai regardé
attentivement
est-ce que c'est elle qui a fait la
vidéo c'est jacqueline tunisair le gilet
jaune de sciez fort bien
si je crois qui est aussi une réaction
dans ce moment une réaction qui est
aussi liée à la déclaration de
d'emmanuel macron lorsqu'il dit
lorsqu'il a dit les français râlent et
je ne lâcherai rien et non mais non mais
je veux simplement que vont expliquer
c'est vrai que je pense que ça a été
ressentie comme une forme de mépris de
classe pour me faire un peu ce sentiment
de rue mais pour unis concrètement et un
peu ce sentiment là d'une façon générale
afin que comme on tient pas compte
valide que la politique est faite plus
tôt pour les premiers de cordée et puis
le reste il paye
hier il ya quand même ce sentiment un
peu généralisés dans le dans la grogne
qu'on voit se développer et notamment
notamment dans l'itinérance mes mains
des manuels may cry un peu ce à quoi
aussi un peu toutes les phrases qu'il a
oui oui il a dit de façon non mais il
répond j'ai appris c'est enfin pour eux
c'est quoi c'est 7 centimes pour le
gasoil 4 centimes pour le vin pour pour
des gens ça représente beaucoup de
choses surtout en prenant la voie des
urnes bourrées valses loire et ça
accentue son image de président des
riches
en effet c'est déjà ça c'est déjà
quelque chose qu'ils ne traînent depuis
la campagne et aujourd'hui voilà on est
dans un petit peu le point d'orgue de
cette grogne qui couvait déjà depuis un
petit moment et puis il vit et
traditions françaises s'étaient phrase
de pompidou les français aiment la
bagnole
tu fais très bien le jour sont vides ou
un faux ami wim de deyne basse après je
ne fais plus que les morts je fais un
spectacle c'est la relation qu'on parle
de pompiers de l'ain des footings voir
les états uniens enfin là aussi les
français aiment la bagnole les
américains des états unis et puis alors
c'est épuisant la face et c'est un
phénomène qui serait impensable je vais
en parler avec un ami de cela il n'y a
pas si longtemps que ça il faisait mais
non ça chez nous c'est inconcevable
serait la révolution de manière absolue
en gros quand vous faites le plein c'est
à peu près le même prix qu ici sauf que
vous en avez trois fois et demie plus
puisque c'est au gallon c'est vrai c'est
un gars non et c'est pas au litre et
donc voilà on va payer l'essence
oui trois fois et demie à quatre fois
moins chère que oui et ce souvent des
gros 4 4 un peu moins maintenant enfin
quoique aussi dans l'amérique profonde
georges tron est vrai mais voilà
vraiment il ya une mentalité extrêmement
extrêmement différentes là c'est moins
pire chez nous quand même alors vous
aviez raison dans les clients ce
mémorial de d'emmanuel macron il y à la
rencontre avec les français et puis il
ya le mémorial justement il ya les
tenais renseigner le moment et le
mémorielle c'est donc le lait sont en de
du 11 novembre 1918 de l'armistice et
c'est très intéressant parce que on
s'aime au fond et ça fait depuis à peu
près
2013 qu'on commémore la guerre de 14 et
qu'on l'a commémore en pensant que c'est
quelque chose d'assez consensuel que
c'est une période consortial de
l'histoire et on s'aperçoit que salam
même celle là n'est pas aussi consensuel
qu'on le pense d'abord il ya l'allemagne
est-ce qu'il faut fêter la victoire
contre l'allemagne et donc la défaite de
l'allemagne c'est très embêtant
est-ce qu'il faut vite veut commémorer
la fin de la boucherie mais ça veut dire
que peut-être que les dires jour de
l'armée n'ont pas été aussi
extraordinaire qu'on qu'on le dit et
puis et puis il ya évidemment philippe
pétain qui est là dessus qui s'est
invitée au débat si l'on peut dire avec
la phrase de manuel macro qui faisait la
différence entre la conduite de pétain
pendant la guerre de 14 et sa conduite
en 1940 alors là ça semaine polémique
incroyable qui montrent que voilà on en
a jamais fini avec notre histoire on n'a
jamais fini votre notre passé et
pourtant consensus enfin vous en parler
mais je ce qui est frappant c'est que je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'on vous
parlait beaucoup de 14 parce que c'était
une période de l'histoire voilà c'est
suffisamment éloignée est suffisamment
éloignée
donc on peut chacun peut ton personnel
mais regardez dans le moindre village
français le monument aux morts ça fait
quatre mois que ton petit visage vous
avez six villages n'y a presque plus
personne aujourd'hui vous avez 20 30 40
qui sont à quel point cette cette guerre
après tout les familles à peu près ont
été touchés par ce nom bon un million et
demi de morts français enfin ça a été
emmené dans des conditions atroces et je
demande des conditions atroces oui oui
un seul endroit dans l'écho nation un
peu plus sans doute jamais dans des
conditions formidables m
a fauché le pays d'une manière terrible
donc on pouvait en effet supposer qu'ils
auraient un fort consensus et je crois
que politiquement macro comptait aussi
sauf que bon il s'est pris les pieds
dans le tapis que là est ce que ces
prêts des prix dans le tapis ou pas ce
qu'il dit vrai bon mais simplement on le
dit pas au micro d'un journaliste en
l'espace de trois minutes c'est quelque
chose qui doit être dit à mon avis dans
un discours qui est construit qui est
argumentée et pas en trois minutes comme
ça et là il s'est fait complètement
enfin ces petits gimmicks de golaud
chirac quand il en avait parlé à la même
chose ne faisait pas tout à fait dans
des discours des discours dans un
discours je pense que ça passait très
bien sauf que ladite façon abrupte
rapide
en réponse à un journaliste sur le bord
d'un trottoir tout à coup bah ça flanc
parce que parce que c'est pas
compréhensible surtout que l'entente qui
n'en parle il est tout de suite dans
l'autojustification oreilles un peu du
coup la suspicion de vouloir créer une
polémique nouvelle alors qu'il a raison
tout le monde l'a dit tout ce qu'il a
dit c'est pas la passe qu'il a 10 de
gaulle l'avait des autres filles
historiquement c'est vrai quand même
vrai nom s'est intéressée fleurir ce
futur sur un demi dieu tous les ans a
déclenché quand même des polémiques
jusqu'à la sphère bousquet c'était une
conception très oui alors il y avait six
mois options aussi avec laquelle rompu
jacques chirac qui était est ce que
c'est la france ou pas la france c'est
vrai que de gaulle mais jusqu'à 8 et
enfin puisque c'est détroit qui se sont
succédé à la présidence implique on
considère vichy n'était pas la france
donc il n'y avait pas de responsabilité
de l'état français sur ce qu'avait fait
vichy et chirac a rompu avec cette
vision là mais la question que ça
pouvait y ait plusieurs questions mais
c'est vrai quand on parle par exemple de
philippe pétain c'est un peu est-ce que
c'est comme si on me disait de la
révolution est ce que c'est un tout un
bloc et donc quand on parle d'une
personnalité on n'a pas distingué ce
qu'il a fait de bien et ce qu'il a fait
de mal mais
identité ou est-ce que l'on peut
distinguer entre des périodes de sont
essayés à emmanuel macron de faire
qualifier d'habitude c'est le et en même
temps donc guy plus tard c'était à
l'homme quand le héros 14-18 et en même
temps sauf que le et en même temps on a
parlé des anciens résidents
les temps ont changé et c'est un peu ce
que ce qui est mais il a un autre grief
c'est qu'il est très jeune et donc du
coup on est un petit peu le sentiment
que il ne sait pas de quoi il parle et
qu'il est un petit peu c'est comme son
parallèle avec les années 30 on on peut
lui reprocher à la fois d'utiliser des
arguments historiques avec quelque part
assez peu de recul et puis c'est bien
quand même comme les pas comme les
autres la télé réalité qu'ils n'étaient
pas des comme d'hab il a donc c'est vrai
quoi vous croyez
parce que justement un bilan non non non
non mais non mais justement sarkozy
sarkozy hollande sont les deux premiers
présidents n'a pas à ne pas avoir connu
la la la la deuxième guerre ils sont
plutôt bien débrouillés avec ça avec
exactement mais je crois que justement
il a il a peut-être fait l'erreur de
vouloir comme vous le dites c'est paraît
un petit peu dans l'histoire alors que
quelque part la logique jusqu'à présent
était d'en faire un tout et d'essayer
d'expliquer alors on a cette fameuse
amnésie constitutionnel qui a été
organisée par le général de gaulle pour
tout faire pour que vichy ne soit pas la
france pour organiser cette transition
peut-être pour notre mémoire collective
aussi pour qu' il y ait une forme
d'union nationale autour du faiseur de
la france n'a jamais été autre chose que
la france est quand vous opposer le bon
soldat à celui qui a eu des choix funès
comme il l'a dit quelque part pour
diviser dans la société et c'est
peut-être ça qui qui a été maladroite sa
part c'est de vouloir essayer de dire
une vérité historique mais sans prendre
en compte le fait que ici surtout dans
les périodes que l'on vit avec mon une
montée quand même
assez assez assez conséquente pas
uniquement en france 2 delà de la
xénophobie généralisée essayez de parler
pour le vivre ensemble et je pense que
c'est ça qu'il n'a pas privilégié dans
ce discours c'est cette idée de voilà
d'apaiser les tensions et donc d'avoir
un discours pour le coup vraiment et en
même temps c'est à dire un discours plus
consensuel et c'était puisque voilà pour
la jeunesse et le ce que vont poser très
bien c'est le rôle quel est le rôle d'un
président de la république qu'est ce que
c'est de dire l'histoire nous de dire
une sorte gabrovo national américain de
météorologie
le récit national avec elle si c'est que
d'une part pétain était le alors plus ou
moins objectivement clemenceau laissé
entendre qu'il avait fallu pousser
pétain etc
il a mangé sa place et c'était peut-être
pas le héros condé cueilli mais enfin ça
reste avec moi dans les voiles mais je
me souviens très bien les airs et grands
parents me racontant à quel point pétain
était était nanti une aura
extraordinaire existe d'autres qu'il
arrive au pouvoir d'ailleurs exactement
et puis d'autre part en 1939-40 la
vérité historique et celle ci c'est
qu'une immense majorité des français
étaient sans être des pétainistes
convaincu étaient convaincus par cette
théorie du glaive et du bouclier
le bouclier était à vichy le glaive
était à londres et que globalement
l'honneur de la france serait sauvé de
cette manière là je ne dis pas que tous
les français étaient des
collaborationnistes où les résistants du
du 5 juin 1944 qu'il y en a fallu dire
pétain en 44 corps et chf et moi j'en
sais rien je ne juge pas non l'histoire
m sauf en effet peut-être qu'on attend
d'un président on attend oui peut-être
de se situer beaucoup plus dans le récit
dans le récit national dans l'histoire
en devenant l'histoire nous visent a mis
à attaquer assez pouvant table à
l'elysée surtout je crois que finale
fonce dans les squares ils n'étaient pas
prévus n'étaient pas prévus dans
j'ai essayé c'était je crois d'après ce
que j'ai compris une demande de l'armée
mais mes gars fin mai par l'aiea et être
a été très déçu et l'armée qui a demandé
justement on puisse célébrer les
maréchaux ce qui est d'ailleurs en plus
axée vraiment créé une autre polémique
parce que les stars y en aurait expliqué
que la grande guerre c'était surtout la
victoire des des soldats est patent des
dommages des soldats aux maréchaux 20
alors évidemment plus symboliquement les
étés passés ou devrait finalement tenir
bon mais le en fait ce qu'on veut ce
qu'on peut lui reprocher surtout c'est
finalement son rétropédalage
parce que au départ effectivement ils
voulaient célébrer il était question de
célébrer hui les huit maréchaux c'est
elle indiqué dans le document qui était
commun qui était donné à la presse
et ensuite donc il a parfaitement assumé
en disant ce qu'il a dit à propos de
pétain et en effet quand c'était que
c'était un grand soldat et dans un
second temps il a été question de ne
plus le fait de ne plus célébrer le
maréchal détient les eaux dénoncer les
vrais que ceux qui sont qui sont
invalides et c'est ça qui nourrit un
petit peu justement le comment dirais-je
la polémique puisque finalement va en
tout cas qui qui permet de douter un
petit peu de
de cette stature de chef d'état mâcon
puisque finalement il n'assume plus
cette idée sur laquelle voilà pétain
était l'homme complexe qui la décrit
c'est surtout qu'il était plus maréchal
enfin il a été déchu c'est paradoxal
avec les politiques qu'on a eue de
déchéance de nationalité les grands
débats qu'on a eu à la fin de 2015 en
nous disant finalement il faut tout
rejeter en bloc et le caractère
nucléaire de ce que vous avez fait quand
vous avez atteint à la nation doit
amener à tout rejeter en bloc donc est
ce qu'on peut vraiment célébrer le
soldat on nous a plutôt défendu l'
inverse depuis quelques temps donc je
pas sûr que les français soient encore
apte à distinguer aussi honnêtement
donc voilà le glaive et le bouclier
c'est vrai que cette thèse que défend
toujours eric geboers le champion
outre qu comparaison historique qui est
assez intéressante c'est celle qui a
fait d'emmanuel macron avec sur l'europe
mais des historiens à la fois aussi avec
des états unis avec ce qui se passait et
a dit la comparaison avec plein de ce
qui se passait dans les années 30 c'est
à dire au fond montée des nationalismes
rejet de l'immigration aujourd'hui
montée du populisme et d'immigration
alors certains disent les périodes
totalement différente
d'autres disent là correspondent à la
comparaison peut valoir votre sentiment
là-dessus ça fait quarante ans qu'on
nous dit que on a le sentiment d'être
dans les années 30
ah oui il me semble attention nous
sommes dans les années 30
l'histoire bégaie mira je ne crois pas
penser qu'il ne repasse jamais les plats
commandes croît toujours un peu arrangé
différentes non vous ne trouvez pas ta
comparaison soit elle tient elle cherche
à inventer des assurés du soir
aujourd'hui on ne s'était pas les
nationalismes d'avant il est resté le
parti unique c'est l extermination des
opposants politiques
c'était un antisémite à la même chair de
guerre mais c'est bien en tant que les
chiffres sur l'antisémitisme c'est plus
innocente % d'actes les zones est là
c'est bien sûr pour savoir de quelle
antisémitisme il s'agit je suis pas sûr
que ça soit le même antisémite et on
sait que dans les années 50 les nouveaux
registres et gic n'est pas un programme
politique qui maintenant nous avons par
par les nationalismes d'aujourd'hui il
ya des éléments de comparaison mais
quelques barrages
oui il ya des éléments de comparaison
voilà ce caractère un peu xénophobe on
n'est plus en train devient l'étranger
sont chez nous mais bon il ya l'idée
quand même cobas hausse enfin une idée
qu'on va s'en sortir on refait en se
refermant sur soi c'était quand même une
idée forte des années 30 et qu'on revoit
aujourd'hui non oui mais je suis fâché
pas moi cette idée alors elle est plus
ou moins audible mais moi je vais
toujours j'ai toujours entendu cette
petite musique avec plus ou moins de
deux belles sauf que l'impressionnant
wallis attendant le 200 dames séverine
voilà c'est largement au pouvoir mais
enfin c'est vrai que jean baptiste a
raison regarder le paysage européen dans
les années au milieu des années 30 enfin
on est pas on n'a pas de mussolini en
italie on n'a pas caudillo en espagne
salazar au portugal un hitler
enfin tout cela n'est pas un n'est pas
comparable
les termes ont un sens oui ne mélangeons
pas que vous avez raison de souligner
qu' il respecte jusqu'à présent au
grosso modo plus fin de l'année 10 mai
les procédures démocratiques enfin
nathalie oui les démocraties libérales
sont enfin jédir hélas ou heureusement
démocratique
bien qu'elle soit est certain le
revendique sorbonne revendiquer le thème
de la démocratie libérale sondés lui
valérie sont élus ils sont majoritaires
et donc on va voir ce qu'on va voir et
on fait ce pour quoi on a été lu et dans
ce pour quoi on a été lu il faut virer
ceux qui sont pas comme nous il faut bon
c'est plus ou moins car les années 30 oc
n'a pas eu uniquement des prises de
pouvoir complètement népotique il ya eu
pas mal de personnes qui sont entrées
dans les formes générales
mais la comparaison a ses limites bien
utilisé par exemple la teneur des débats
qu'on pouvait avoir à la chambre en
france du violon set mais c'était
certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils vont
table c'était terrible souvenez-vous
lorsque enfin je vais l'action française
il est grand boum s'exprimait à la
chambre alors c'était ça c'était après
je pense à ma ds france pareil on
entendait des insultes antisémites
épouvantable on l'appelait faisait qu'il
faut lui si mal et c'est qu'il fallut le
posait y planter des couteaux dans le
dos so lu ment enfin d'affaires il y
avait un discours police alors le
discours politique se crispe on le sent
bien devient de plus en plus violent
mais on n'est pas en voilà au point où
nous en étions dans ces années là
non mais quand on quand on fait la
comparaison c'est aussi pour dire
attention effet salutaire
est-ce qu'on n'est pas sur la voie 2 a
un effet sur une aile je pense pas qu'il
est neutre ce débat je pense que
emmanuel macron là aussi utilisé pour
dire voilà on fait attention on peut
basculer et dans des pays à risque dans
dans un régime autocratique et je suis
là parce que je suis dans le camp des
réformistes et j'ai ça va être le thème
de la campagne des européennes ça les
calme de la campagne peine ému je trouve
que justement le fait de deux quêtes
caricaturé comme ça à l'extrême
justement c'est nationalisme
et alors peut-être politiquement habile
pour lui mais je trouve que c'est quand
même dangereux parce que ça donne le
sentiment que comment dirais je
enfin on peut pas avoir la reproduire
les schémas d'avant et je crois que
c'est une manoeuvre politique plus
qu'une lutte justement qui dit j'aime
dire l'histoire comme elle est et non
pas l'inventer là pour le coup je crois
que la caricature un petit peu épicé le
débat qu'on avait eue avec le front
national finalement beaucoup avaient
diaboliser ce fameux mouvement en
refusant en bloc et donc du coup on en
faisant une forme d' ennemi sans nom
alors que il aurait peut-être parfois
été plus utile de voile à le reconnaître
pour le combattre et c'est vrai que
quand vous diaboliser en dix ans et
populisme sont finalement des fascismes
déguisez vous vous ne prenez pas
l'ennemi en face en le respectant dans
sa qualité d' ennemi lui aussi élu sur
le suivant les formes démocratiques et
voilà en donnant plus de sens à ce débat
en crise pas un petit peu les voilà les
oppositions juste un peu dangereux du
coup bon c'est clair
la campagne qui s'achemine pour les
présidentielles c'est dire progressiste
contre nationale 10
c'est pas une bonne idée ça c'est yahia
voilà il y en a qui disent oui ça va
être ça le vrai débat et d'autres qu'ils
aient attention là on est en train de
diaboliser et c'est pas comme ça que ça
va ça va ça va pas marcher c'est surtout
qu'est ce que sont les progressistes
qu'on a du mal à voir alors les
nationalistes c'est ce que dit ma croix
c'est ce que l'europe qu'incarne me
emmanuelle mais c'est cette europe là
qu'il faudrait arriver à définir c'est à
dire quand on voit assez clairement quel
est le projet politique des populistes
dd oui voilà d'aidé médicale réforme de
l'europe il faudrait faire
à l'europe à laquelle il faut croire à
laquelle on a tous envie de croire quand
on est pro européen qu'on a du mal à
dessiner à l'heure actuelle donc
peut-être que plutôt que d'opposer les
forces de cette manière là alors qu'il
crie il risque de crisper le débat
emmanuel macron devrait aussi faire
usage de ce qu'il avait dit dans la
campagne de la pédagogie aussi pour
expliquer un discours sur bangkok était
certain recul et est inquiète et un
discours vraiment fondateur d'une
nouvelle vision de l'europe que là je
trouve qu'ils utilisent assez peu alors
que la campagne vient de commencer mais
il serait peut-être bien d'utiliser les
ressorts de la pédagogie plutôt que de
la crispation pour nous dire bon voilà
nous l'europe qu'on défend et celle ci
et le repli national pourrait être
risqué pour d'autres raisons mais avec
des difficultés que la situation de
l'anglais merkel veut épouser pour pour
cette europe
cette vision là de l'europe c'est la
technocratie européenne qui est toujours
le problème c'est qu'on a le sentiment
que l'union européenne représente un
petit peu tous les impératifs d'une
certaine politique qu emmanuel macron
malheureusement pour lui incarne un peu
aussi avec cette idée des élites
gouvernantes qui sont déconnectés du
socle populaire finalement et je crois
que c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
de les opposer aussi au cinéma il faut
toujours apprécié actionnaires bruxelles
que l'amérique paris mais c'est vrai
quand on parle de technocratie et que
c'est pas mal de faire fonctionner une
organisation comme lieu comme l'union
européenne avec en effet moins d'agents
que kelvin de pain et alors il ya cette
comparaison avec les années 30 et des
historiques l'ont reprise aussi pour les
états unis montée de l'isolationnisme
enfin repli repli sur soi
là aussi roger d d d immigration et
victoire de trump enfin victoire de
trappes justement qu'un train de mixer
c'est exceptionnel mais qui perd la
chambre des représentants le sénat et le
gouvernement
oui comme pour lui ok quand même une à
mal oui et vous prépare sa réélection
comme un peu en plus ou moins de tout à
fait il a été très présent en plus dans
cette campagne avec un toujours son
caractère très alarmiste en disant que
sans ça c'était un petit peu après les
luges il l'a fait la corrida commun
voilà il a réussi il a réussi à
convaincre que il avait besoin de
soutien bon il reste que l'opposition
démocrate est quand même là bien là à la
chambre des représentants des
commissions d'enquêté pourront être
constituées vont certainement oui c'est
important dans la chambre des
représentants c'est important d'avoir la
chambre des représentants bien sûr pour
le budget pour les nominations pour
voilà pour lens un contre-pouvoir la la
la chambre est quand même conçu comme un
entrepôt fait mettre un terme à l'
enquête sur sur l' influence russe
je suis pas sûr qu'ils puissent utiliser
les jambes contre une autre à ce niveau
là n'ont que nos jeunes ans que j'ai cru
comprendre non après douvry façon
jusqu'où iront ces commission denquête
ça c'est un pari qu'on ne peut pas
encore mené mais ils peuvent en créer
l'une de celles à n'y pourra rien ces
bonnes
je sais pas vous disiez m amp le repli
et c'est alors ça se faisait sur un
autre mode mais les deux mandat d'obama
oui il avait commencé ont aussi consacré
seulement de manière moins carré comme
elle râle une nouvelle nouveau
positionnement des états unis d'amérique
au sur la scène internationale avec un
repli de très clair il était aussi dans
le discours de mama 2 2
on entendait de manière assez clair que
les états unis n'entendait plus assumer
ce rôle du gendarme de la paix c'est
grave parce que ça avait un coût non
seulement et parce que les priorités
étaient ailleurs non plus ce rôle de
soutien presque inconditionnelle de
l'europe
on sait aujourd'hui que l'union
européenne est plutôt perçue comme
adversaires des états unis c'est très
regrettable même si je pense que nous
restons et resterons des alliés dernier
aux alliés historiques
enfin il ya quand même de l'eau dans le
gaz donc ce se replie était amorcée nous
n'avons pas mais ça mais dans les années
30 se reprit a eu des conséquences
graves quand même ils ont tissé oui puis
alors mais dans les années qui ont suivi
regarder chez pas je pensais je lisais
un truc il n'ya pas longtemps sur le sur
mac carthy dans les années 50 mais
c'était un repli intérieur c'est à dire
que c'était l'ennemi de l'intérieur le
communisme où le supposé communiste
qu'il fallait pour chasser c'est elle
est très très loin comme aimait à le
capter alors fake ou le maire civile au
siècle passé enfin oui on voit on voit
la liste l'histoire des états unis est
un peu enfin l'image déjà le sentiment
qui peut se passer le pire comme le
meilleur dans ce dans cette culture là
peut-être un mot sur la nouvelle
calédonie alors lié ce référendum est
généralement les pouvoirs assez peur
maintenant des référendums celui-là
quand même été plutôt venir préparer
parce que les accords de matignon sa
veuve de 88
donc il eu 30 ans de préparation
est ce que c'est le temps qu'il faut
pour contraindre réussi
c'est une bonne occasion au point un
référendum au 6ème jour et pour diwan à
christian déposé son bilan fin c'est pas
de sonder référendum d'un titre quand
même relativement particulier puisqu'en
plus bon vous n'insultez pas toute la
population française mais la population
uniquement concerné et il faut dire qu
on est parti très loin quand même avec
dont justement ces accords de 88 la
situation risque de devenir ce que c'est
toi la situer sur 88 explosive oui on y
marche encore sur des jeeps ou était
accessible par tout à fait l'extrémiste
qui est reproché d'avoir parlé c'est
pour ça que reçoit son bon bord enfin
pas d'un seul coup
non mais la crise calédonienne
antérieure à l'arrivée de michel rocard
c'est 70 tués c'est horrible donc c'est
peut-être peut-être que le temps moyen
pour arriver à apaiser les esprits sur
cette question ses 30 ans je ne sais pas
these voilà mûrement réfléchie préparé
avec d'outreau courbis qui pourra y
avoir d'autres référendum d'ailleurs
et donc voilà il ya eu quelques quelques
exactions m'enfin ça s'est passé dans un
climat plutôt apaisé dans l'ensemble
c'est vrai c'est un pasito succès doit
beaucoup à l'attitude du gouvernement
qui justement y en a justement n'a pas
joué la métropole compte sur la nouvelle
calédonie et ça permet vraiment de faire
que ce référendum soit sur l'exemplaire
la question c'est la suite tout de suite
parce que comme dirait quelqu'un tous
les kanaks n'ont pas voté pour
l'indépendance mais tous ceux qui ont
voté pour l'indépendance sont des kanaks
exactement ça pose c'est vrai que le
problème n'est pas résolu le problème
n'est pas résolu notamment parce que
l'on mène dans la constitution est ce
qu'on pourra rester dans dans ce type
d'accord qui sont quand même
profondément dérogatoire
a priori non il va falloir quand même
stabilisé le statut et puis est-ce que
l'organisation même de ce référendum ne
peut pas donner des idées aux 6,1 c'est
un peu ça mais le voilà on est en train
de parler différenciation territoriale
alors combien la situation qu'attendu il
avait fondé le front de libération des
limousins bien entendu l'indépendance de
l'île de ré a été primé en 68
parisse mais par une belle percée mais
biais des petites républiques en force
qui existe sur wii sur le floride dans
le jura mais non non vous de voir
comment ce référendum va être perçue
mais mais qui pensait pas que ça allait
être aussi serré genre de résultats que
si c'était la victoire
c'est vrai que si 70% c'était des choses
étaient un peu différentes
ouais mais c'est une réussite aussi
enfin probablement me semble-t-il parce
que depuis
l'accord de nouméa intervenir dix ans
plus tard 90 la nouvelle calédonie est
devenue un territoire très à part et
charlène le soulignait au sein de la
république certes c'est quand même le
territoire qui ça n'est même plus une
collectivité territoriale
c'est une collectivité sui generis et
erguy la seule dans sa catégorie qui
dispose de compétences extrêmement dense
extrêmement nombreuses compétences qui
ont été transférés par la métropole
jusqu'à une compétence d'ordre
législatif dire que la
nouvelle-calédonie peut défaire ce que
le législateur à paris a fait cet unique
évidemment dans ce sud dans la situation
républicaine donc il ya eu un glissement
progressif depuis 98 vers une situation
non pas d'indépendance mais de très très
forte autonomie de très forte autonomie
et manifestement la nouvelle calédonie a
su se saisir de manière assez subtile et
intelligente des compétences qui lui ont
été transférés jeu comparaison n'est pas
raison mais à la différence de la corse
par exemple il est aussi fine que toutes
choses étant égales par ailleurs n'a pas
de compétence législative et c'est un
mec qui est une collectivité qui dispose
d'un d'un nombre très très accrue de
compétences et qui jusqu'à présent ne
les exercent pas tout
donc il ya eu une intelligence locale
une récurrence calédonienne un peu déçu
politique même même si les gouvernement
calédonien sont extrêmement instable
parce que justement ils doivent être
paritaires cana caldoches extrêmement
délicat ya eu la querelle je vois les
drapeaux et la querelle des drapeaux a
fait savoir qu'elle devait être le
drapeau de la nouvelle paire de ligne
celui de la kanaky d'un côté la
république de l'autre ça c'est un
compromis qui a fait tomber deux fois le
gouvernement calédonien sur une question
comme ça ça veut dire que
la question très sensible encore tout
est fragile mais c'est vrai vous avez
raison de souligner quand même quel quel
parcours
au cours de ces 30 enfin je pense qu'il
ya un exemple et puis quelques exemples
de pacification
jeu set et rocard tout à l'heure enfin
quelle quelle intelligence quelle
subtilité que d'avoir quand même pas s'y
fier c'est ça reste fragile mais ce que
cela soit bien séduire 88 ans juste
avant les élections et sauter c'était
quand même extrêmement ton site est
violent est-ce que vous avez vu cette
explication qui s'appelle dans ma rue
non non c'est non mais c'est une
application alors ou civique ou de
délation comment dire voilà quand vous
voyez quelque chose qui vous semblent sa
part une voiture mal garée des gens qui
mettent des ordures devant celle de teta
vous vous pouvez voilà prendre la photo
et le mettre sur cette application est
donc vous dénoncez un petit peu les gens
qui font ça c'est nul mais une
numérisation de la délation lundi matin
sujet juste après pétain oui est ce que
les réseaux sociaux ne ramène pas assez
petites lettres qu'on écrivait pauvres
regardez 9,7 autre chose mais me to dont
on se re gorge et on dit un an plus tard
quel succès de ces terrains ça fait sans
doute évoluer les choses c'est un truc
épouvantable où chacune peut balancer un
nom le nom d'un type alors passé
peut-être parfois justifiées ou pas mais
c'est un truc horrible c'est vrai un
truc épouvantable
il faut s'en émouvoir 6
ça dans ma rue mais est-ce que mais est
ce que on dénonce une personne bien ce
qu'on sait faire et font bien attention
à pas utiliser le terme de dommages qui
du coup en fait au rayon un devis des
conséquences sur l'anomalie qu'on
constate sur les voies publiques mais
pas uniquement public c'est à dire
vraiment n'importe où où nous le
souhaitons nous estimons qu'un
comportement non civique a été commis et
lyon restent anonymes ou à oui ça c'est
pas normal il faudrait que dans cette
application c'est justement pour éviter
les combats
c'est vrai que et non irritant mais
quelqu'un qui dit l'autre jour il y
avait vu un type déposer des meubles
sans avoir prévenu les encombrants à
terra et la personne libre ça ne se
dépose pas la ld je t'emmerde était sa
gueule alors évidemment sa navigation
l'application après se passe quoi donc
bal après la mairie alors lu le
témoignage de quelqu'un qui faisait
justement qu'il avait des gens qui
avaient déposé guys et après la photo
mise sur le sur le site et les
encombrants sont passées très vite quoi
par exemple c'est peut-être alors est ce
que c'est bon alors est ce que quelqu'un
disait mais il serait passé
[Rires]
c'est assez intéressant hrw a beau il
nous reste plus de temps non il nous
reste 30 secondes donc on n'a même pas
le temps d'aborder la question des
premiers heurts
ils sont jolis en trio je voulais vous
dire juste que le medef fait ce type
d'opération chefs d'entreprise et
gendarmerie
et ben voilà vive l'armée les gouttes
savoura un grand succès vive l'armée où
il est barré chou et livre la prof et
les larmes et vient dans les entreprises
après c'est la conclusion de cette
émission autour de l'ar men les plus sur
les champs de bataille merci tous les
cas merci et florence père cadets et à
très vite pour un nouveau parfum
[Musique]
perfore à huy